had a great weekend what'd you do judith
regan came over
and she [ __ ] her brains out too oh my
god she says oh she loves coffee and it
was
the funniest uh moment of the weekend
when we were each in separate areas
having our coffee could you talk to each
other during them no we should have had
walkie talkies what do you mean separate
areas did you i thought you were doing
them at your house but you had to go
somewhere
no no no i was up in my bathroom judith
was in her bathroom
and ronnie was in her bathroom oh was
that triple enemas yes everybody was
doing a coffee enema ronnie with dr
ronnie was animating too yeah wow did
they have one of those coffee urns to
make does it smell like coffee yeah it
smells like coffee like starbucks
it's coffee what kind of coffee
organic coffee after the coffee enema i
felt like i'd had too much coffee but at
another place in your [ __ ] not in the
ass it was in my colon somewhere i was
like i'm not busting your balls but what
i mean like how do you get coffee into
your [ __ ] i mean what
he is saying i don't understand bag and
then i'm a bag
you put coffee you pour hot coc hot
coffee and then you let the coffee cool
right dr ronnie prepares coffee puts it
in an enema bag right and then you go
into the bathroom and tells you how to
inject it i don't even know how to do an
animal i mean like what do you do like
you attach a bag and a hose to your
[ __ ] and then how do you bag is is
like one unit it doesn't have a hose
attached it's all one thing
and then you apply it to the affected
area yeah and then when you squeeze the
bag and it shoots no yeah the bag is
elevated so you un uh you release this
little clamp that's holding the tube
closed and then all the liquid flows
into where it's supposed to do you lay
down on the floor you're on your left
side on the floor i was in my shower
lying on the floor do you ever feel
stupid doing that i mean you just look
at yourself and go how did i get to this
point in my life i'm like well whatever
works um why coffee though why not root
beer root beer doesn't work root beer
enema i'm going to go ahead and do
something i might start the root beer
enema diet
well go for it let's ask dr ronnie i'm
just curious why coffee you know i love
coffee so it was nice to have some
dr ronnie why coffee as opposed to as i
say root beer or some other liquid well
coffee by the way um is an antioxidant
when it opens up the bile ducts really
glutathione it's called glutathione and
glutathione helps your liver the cleanse
and the coffee helps the colon and the
liver at the same time how soon after
the coffee robin you went into you did
you start [ __ ] well you have to hold
it you have to retain it how long did
you retain how long
10 to 15 minutes and i made it to 12 and
then you
really have to go to 12 were you proud
of robin that she could hold it 12
months
but when you heard about how wonderfully
she did
how long did judith hold her call i have
no idea you didn't discuss it 15 minutes
did she she's a 15 minute girl she beat
you
so the coffee you held for 12 minutes
and uh and then everything is released
in the into the bowl and you're saying
turds come out also right yeah yes did
you get a lot out talk to ronnie or are
you such a pro at this point there's
hardly any left no i always do you got a
lot out good and did you have clarity
well i woke up very tired and after the
coffee i uh had my voice back and
everything i was a little raspy really
yeah after the coffee enema you felt all
of a sudden meningitis was back yeah
wow
well dr ronnie voice goes give yourself
a coffee animal that's my recommendation
can't argue that with that kind of
success yeah good for you gals robin
quivers is going nuts
she's pouring coffee inside a bunch
she put some coffee in her
to quit [ __ ] coffee ain't for taking
[ __ ] drinking shakes wrapped like a
mummy you're really looking like such a
dummy
oh for goodness sakes